[MUSIC PLAYING]
COLE MCCANDLESS:
Oh, AsyncTask, how
we have a love/hate
relationship with you.
On the one hand, you
make it really easy
to get work off the main thread.
But on the other hand,
you make it really easy
to do a bunch of
really bad stuff.
My name is Cole McCandless,
and while AsyncTask provides
some easy interfaces,
if you're not careful,
it can hurt your
app's performance
and end up causing memory leaks.
So here is a familiar situation.
The user wipes the
screen, kicking off
some bitmap decoding to occur.
And because that work is
going to take a long time,
you need to hand it
off to another thread
so you don't cause hitching
in your animations.
But once the bitmaps
have been decoded,
you need to get them
back to the UI thread
so that you can
update your views.
If this happens a lot
in your application,
then it's not worth writing
all the one-off code
snippets to make this
happen the right way.
This is exactly why
AsyncTask was created.
It wraps up all of this
gnarliness with three
simple function calls.
Basically, the
OnPreExecute function
will happen on the main
thread and allow you to set up
the work you are about to do.
Then the DoInBackground
function will execute on
a worker thread, actually
doing the computation.
And finally,
OnPostExecute is called
on the main thread, along
with the results of the work
that you've just completed.
Simply overload these three
functions in your own class,
and AsyncTask will do the rest.
Now, while this seems
like an ideal solution,
you need to be cautious.
There are some
nuances with AsyncTask
that can get you into trouble.
Firstly, all AsyncTasks
that are created
will share the same
thread and thus will
execute in a serial fashion
from a single message queue.
So if you kick
off 20 work orders
and the third one takes
an hour, the other 17
will block and wait
until it's done.
This is especially
dangerous if you kick off
some work that's got a long
running while loop in it.
Basically, it'll just
freeze that thread
from doing any future work.
Now, to be fair, there is a way
to force AsyncTask to execute
in a thread-pooled fashion.
But in reality, if you're
venturing into that area,
you might just want to use the
thread pool primitive directly,
instead of all that madness.
Anyhow, the second
big problem might
be a little bit more
familiar; how do you actually
cancel a block of work?
I mean, AsyncTask has this
handy Cancel function,
but what does that really do?
Well, remember that
threads don't directly
contain the ability to
interrupt the current code being
executed.
If you want a
threaded block of work
to be able to terminate early,
you have to do two things.
Number one, add
some logic to check
for a flag that says the
work has been canceled.
And number two, once the
block of work is finished,
let the other functions know
that this packet's results are
invalid.
And this is exactly what the
Cancel function in AsyncTask
does.
It will set a flag and allow the
IsCanceled function to return
true so your code can
check that regularly
to see if it should exit early.
In addition, after doing
background returns,
a canceled AsyncTask will call
on canceled on the UI thread
instead of on PostExecute.
This is so you can
properly update your UI
or destroy specific memory
allocations that you might not
need any more,
yadda, yadda, yadda.
And finally, be aware that
it's really, really easy
to leak memory with AsyncTask.
Check out this very common
seen-all-the-time code pattern
in Android apps, where
an AsyncTask is declared
as an inner class
of some activity.
This is a really big problem.
Having AsyncTask declared
as an inner class
creates an implicit reference
to the outer activity, which
can then result in
leaked memory, which
means it won't be destroyed
until the AsyncTask
work completes.
Obviously, this
is less than ideal
if you're trying to
load a new activity
and you still have several
destroyed activities in memory
since their work
hasn't been completed.
The gist here is that while
AsyncTask makes it really easy
to move work off
the UI thread, it's
far from being a silver bullet.
So don't be afraid
to check out some
of the other threading
primitives in Android
in case you need a little
different use case.
For example, HandlerThreads
are great when
you need a dedicated thread
for callbacks to land on.
ThreadPools work
best when you've
got a mountain of small
work objects to do.
And IntentServices are really
ideal for background tasks
or when you need to get intent
work off of the UI thread.
And see, that's the
whole thing when
it comes to
performance coding; you
have to understand enough
about the primitives to know
how they might help you and
how they might hurt you.
And if it's not working, move
on to a better pattern, which
is why you should check out the
rest of the Android Performance
Patterns videos.
And don't forget to ask your
hard threading questions
in the Google+
community as well.
So keep calm, profile your
code, and always remember
perf matters.
[MUSIC PLAYING]